les chéris samedi soir sur tf1 il y
avait un nouveau prime time the voice
est longue donc l'audience était encore
une fois en baisse 5,2 millions de
téléspectateurs c'est quand même pas mal
du tout perdre quand même trois cent
mille téléspectateurs en une semaine
brard d'audience quasiment stable oui si
on se réfère à la première émission du
27 janvier ses millions 400 mille
là on est à 4 millions $ et ferronnier
oui le vrai problème c'est que
l'audience en elle-même allait pas
mauvaise oui mais il paye l'émission
tellement cher mais moi je me suis
relancé sur le tarif de la pub leur
conviendrait passée de 108 mille à la
meilleure époque à 70000 aujourd'hui ce
qu'évite sur coup trois millions et demi
allez allez venant à elle est vendue 2
contre 1 millions et millions 2,1
millions de jeunes est à sa 5 millions
en termes de rentabilité c'est là où
après le score et là vraiment on va voir
il ya eu polémique samedi soir dans the
voice est cette jeune fille qui a été
éliminée foule avec son ex avec son
extinction pouvoir regarder rapide j'ai
une extinction de voix
hier dans l'après midi voilà
- une page en temps
de toute façon à nous c'est notre
cauchemar devant les musiciens d'abord
un super coach et de pour rien furent de
peu pour travailler c'est hyper
frustrant
si jamais ça peut pas se traiter en
temps et en heure et tu veux pas chanter
en expliquera qu'un abandon qu'elle est
liée à un problème technique
je prie pour que l'ol mais disent que je
vais chanter
[Musique]
alors oui donc je vous le dis elle a été
éliminée est ce que vous trouvez que
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui ont
rallié sur twitter qui disent qu'ils
n'auraient pas dû l'éliminer en fait
c'est absurde ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
un choix bâtard soit on la fait chanter
quand sa voix est rétabli on attend un
peu son la fais pas chanter mais là on
l'envoie au casse pipe
il est évident qu'elle ne pouvait pas
être choisis donc on l'a sacrifié sur
l'autel d'une audience heure à l'autre
il dit n'importe quoi
c'est une compétition voilà donc si
nadal est blessé en fait on n'en
attendait rien n'est justement mon
poignet va se remettre je suis assez
d'accord avec toi les batailles celle
d'hier est classé enregistrés mais
l'asie où la compétition là elle joue
avec deux autres il ya bien sûr il faut
avec deux autres la vie d'artiste
ok c'est la hantise de tous les artistes
ne pas avoir de voix que j'aimerais
qu'ils doivent se produire mais ça
arrive très souvent c'est pour ça que à
un moment où des gens se moquaient un
petit peu de ces lignes on passe qui est
préservé sa voix mais c'est très
fréquent chez les chanteurs alors on
voudrait vous montrer une autre
prestation kaboul après parler c'est
celle des co non non j'ai dû tout gilles
si on l'a eue contre et il avait attendu
qu'elle se rétablisse très bien c'est un
scandale je dirais non
ils ont attendu pour qu'elle puisse
gagner et c'est donc là il aurait établi
le chemin habituel
voilà bah oui pas faire autant dans ce
sens et la cie il connaît très bien
aujourd'hui alors une reprise du célèbre
tube voyage voyage de desireless
regardez ce que ça a donné apparemment
ça beaucoup plus sur les réseaux sociaux
je vous dis la vérité je n'ai pas vu
l'émission car il y avait des combats de
boxe sur canal+ ah oui ce soir là voilà
donc regarder mais je vous dit voyage
[Musique]
b
jours
pour moi la performance technique la
moins réussie
c'était peut-être celle des co mais
c'est vrai que quand je suis venu aux
répétitions
c'était juste si je dois choisir pour la
performance
j'ai un petit problème mais je vais
quand même de choisir quand même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc j'aime j'aime pas les outils pour
garder son bébé pancartes pas pour
apprendre mais les pancartes les shearim
vous et vous aimez donc voilà j'aime
chez woolworths si vous avez aimé ou
voice samedi soir regardez j'aime 42 pas
1 28% en tout cas ce boys marée jaune
quand même très très très très fort